chris is with us in Illinois hey Chris
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
how's it going it's a pleasure to talk
to the New Jersey you too sir
how can I help well my question is my
dad is he's been was girlfriend for a
little while now and she recently moved
in because she has no income and she she
was getting income before to pay her own
rent to because her ex-husband had
passed away she was the kids were under
18 so that's how she was getting income
anyway she moved in with my dad and then
now she doesn't have any health
insurance or anything and my dad has
asked me if I think it's a good idea for
him to marry her private insurance
because she has some health issues right
now and she doesn't have anything for
net worth or anything like that well
yeah I wouldn't not marry someone
because they had didn't have a net worth
but marrying someone because of health
insurance that sounds pretty lame like
you ought to hear somebody because
you're in love and you want to spend the
life you're the rest of your life with
them that's what I thought I told him I
asked him the question like that would
you want to spend the rest of your life
with her and he says well I don't know
because yes she's got too much baggage
because he's got like a bunch of kids
and stuff like that and they're all
staying at my dad's house right now and
he was asking me what I think you should
do but I really personally how old are
you that I I'm 28 and are you married
I'm not married I have a girlfriend so I
guess I guess he was kind of wanting you
to be okay with having a new stepmom huh
I don't know but we we both work at the
same place and we both make pretty good
money and our health insurance is pretty
good
like we don't listen furnishing health
insurance to someone as a really dumb
reason to marry them yeah that's what I
thought yeah they don't having that
really that's a bad
decision-making paradigm by choosing for
choosing a mate yeah I think you think
he feels sorry for her and wants to help
her and and he's confusing that with a
lifetime commitment
but see I'm an old-school dude I feel
like when you marry someone I the only
way you get rid of them is death yeah
that's exactly what I think I think if
you're going to marry someone it's to be
with them for the rest of your life well
just like you said through rich or yeah
Lauren poor yeah like that in sickness
and in health and for richer for poorer
under thee all my worldly goods I
pledged gladly and I don't have to think
about it in other words I wouldn't be
asking you I would be announcing it to
you that this was occurring yeah I
appreciate the fact that he's asking you
tells you that he doesn't want to do it
he wants somebody to tell him otherwise
he wouldn't be asking his 28 year old
son for permission to get married old
dogs don't do that much often that often